CALUM BARNES: Hi, my name's
Calum Barnes from Google Cloud.
I'm the Product Manager
for Cloud Speech,
and today, I'm
going to be talking
about measuring and improving
speech-to-text accuracy
with the Google
Cloud speech product.
First, I'm going to give you
a little bit of an overview
on Cloud Speech-to-Text.
Then I'm going to talk
about how you can measure
the accuracy of speech
to text on your own data
then what you can do using our
tools to improve that accuracy
once you've measured it.
And finally, I will do a quick
worked example at the end
and link you out to some of the
companion tools and examples
that we've created to go with
this next on-air presentation.
So Google Cloud Speech-to-Text
is a API which accepts audio.
It identifies speech
within that audio
and returns the text
representation of that speech.
This happens in real
time or in batch mode.
We support both in all
71 languages and 127
local variants that we support.
We also have, for each
one of these languages,
a massive vocabulary that goes
far beyond the dictionary.
It covers local vernacular,
proper nouns, et cetera.
Today, we're going to be
especially focused on the tools
that we have for
customizing the API
and improving recognition
on specific terms
as well as doing things like
changing the output formatting.
So let's jump in and start
talking about speech accuracy.
Accuracy is pretty much
the most important thing
when it comes to speech to text.
So whether you're doing
post-processing on the text
to determine someone's
intent and extract entities
or displaying the text
directly to users for captions,
having a higher quality
transcript that's more accurate
is going to result in a better
user experience either way.
There are a whole
number of factors
that can affect speech
accuracy, from background noise
to audio quality to
various different accents
or strange verbalizations,
and all of these things
can have a big impact.
At Google Cloud and
Google as a whole,
we have tried to make our
models as robust as possible,
and this means that they should
work really, really well right
out of the box on a
wide variety of types
of speech and other scenarios.
But all speech
recognition systems
are very sensitive to
input data, and that means,
when you think about
accuracy, you really
need to be thinking about,
what is the accuracy
of this system on
my specific data,
in my recorded environment,
the types of speakers I have,
the types of speech it is?
And to do that, you
have to measure it,
and to measure it
we need to have
a common language for how we
talk about what the quality
level is.
And in Speech-to-Text, usually
that's Word Error Rate or WER.
WER or Word Error Rate
is not the only way
to measure speech
accuracy, but it certainly
is the most common,
and even if you're also
looking at other metrics,
which can be valuable,
usually they're looked at in
conjunction with Word Error
Rate as well.
Word Error Rate is composed
of three different types
of errors that can happen
during transcription.
One is the number of insertions.
So these are words which are
present in the hypothesis
or the machine-generated,
in this case,
transcript that are not
present in the actual ground
truth accurate transcript.
Substitutions are the number of
words which are present but are
mistranscribed as
a different word
or formatted in
an incorrect way,
and finally, deletions
are the number
of words which are
completely missing
from the hypothesis
transcript which
are supposed to be present
in the source audio or ground
truth transcript.
You add up all three
of these numbers,
and you divide by the
total number of words
that exist in the
ground truth reference,
and that gives you the
overall word error rate.
This means that it is actually
possible for a Word Error Rate
to be greater than
100% in situations
where you have very,
very poor quality.
So to measure Word
Error Rate, we
have a few steps you can
follow, and we've also
created a bunch of tools to
make it as easy as possible.
But it all starts with
getting your audio files.
Like I said before, if you
want to measure accuracy
and how the system is going to
perform in how you're using it,
you must have
in-domain audio which
is similar to what
you're going to be doing.
Generally, we recommend having
about three hours in this test
set, but you can still
get pretty statistically
significant results with
as little as 30 minutes
of in-domain audio.
It's more important
that the audio
is similar and
representative of what you're
trying to transcribe than
it is to have a ton of it.
The second step is probably
the hardest of all of them.
You have to get the ground
truth for this audio.
So this means you must have
the human-transcribed 100%
or as close to 100% as
possible accurate version
of the transcribed
audio in order
to compare the various
hypotheses against.
The third step is easy.
You get your machine
transcription
by sending it to the
Cloud Speech API,
and then finally, you can
compute the Word Error Rate
with our simple WER
script where you
feed in the hypothesis
and the ground truth.
And we will show you what
the Word Error Rate is.
That script, in
addition telling you
the number of insertions,
deletions, and substitutions,
will also give you this pretty
printed HTML that will show you
exactly where each error is
and what type of error it is,
and you can see a
sample of that here.
So now that you've measured
the accuracy of your audio,
it's time to think
about what you
can do to improve the
accuracy on your test set
and on your wider
set, and we do this
with a set of tools that allow
us to help customize the model
or customize the system
towards the type of audio
that we're sending it.
Broadly speaking, there's
three different ways
to think about improving
speech accuracy through model
customization.
The first is to customize
the model to your domain
by providing
contextual information.
An example of this
would be if you
knew that people we're going
to be talking about pizza
or ordering pizza.
You could bias towards
different types
of crust, different
types of cheese,
different toppings, et cetera.
Next is to tweak weights to
address specific word or phrase
issues.
So commonly this can
occur with proper nouns,
people's names, or maybe it's
individual product names,
but words which,
generally speaking,
occur very rarely in all speech.
Number three is to
use context that you
have to bias towards
specific types of information
or specific situations.
So for example, if you
had a phone system IVR,
you might know that a user is
about to tell you an account
number or a phone
number, and you
can tell the ASR
system to only look
for a digit sequence or
a alphanumeric sequence.
We support doing all three
types of these customizations
in Google Cloud Speech
through the use of our speech
adaptation tools.
These tools, if used correctly,
can be extremely powerful
and can shift quality
very significantly
depending on the situation and
the type of bias in what you're
doing.
Before we get into the
features of speech adaptation
and exactly how to
use them, though, I
want to talk a little bit about
how speech adaptation works
and how that's somewhat
different from other types
of model customization.
In order to talk about
how we customize the model
and customize the
results, we need
to understand a little bit
more about how ASR or Automatic
Speech Recognition systems work.
Now, this is a extremely
simplified diagram,
and not all speech
recognition systems
work in this exact same way.
But it will help us
illustrate the point here.
So a very simple system would
take audio input in from a user
into what's called
an acoustic model.
The acoustic model
looks at the audio wave
forms or the spectrogram, and
it converts these wave forms
into sounds which it thinks are
there, also known as phonemes.
The language model then looks
at the groupings and series
of phonemes and
tries to understand
from those sounds which words
or phrases are being said.
Most language models also
take context and other factors
into account when
determining the text which
the phonemes represent.
Some models will
produce a single output,
or perhaps it will have
n best alternatives that
could be determined from
that grouping of phonemes.
Now let's take a look
at the simplified
version of the Google
Speech-to-Text API.
The audio comes into
an acoustic model
and is converted
to phonemes that
are set to the
language model, just
like we talked about before.
The difference is two things.
One is the language model
produces, instead of
just a single highest confidence
hypothesis or a series
of n best alternatives-- but
it produces an entire lattice
of potential word alternatives.
The other difference is
the speech adaptation API,
which allows users to
send context and word
hints about what the
audio might contain.
This information is then used
to operate on the word lattice
and determine, based
on these hints as well
as the confidences from
the language model, what
the highest confidence
hypothesis text is as well
as n best alternatives if that's
interesting to [INAUDIBLE]..
This differs slightly from other
types of model customization
where you might have a
custom language model where
the entire language
model itself is changed
to account for
specific proper nouns
or various different sequences
which might be expected.
But the great part
about speech adaptation
is there's no training
or retraining required,
so it's much easier to
experiment and much cheaper
to adapt the model to a
variety of different needs.
Next is it happens
completely in real time,
so we're able to
compute these changes
without adding any latency to
the end-to-end ASR pipeline.
And this also means,
because there is no training
and it happens in real time,
you can have a different context
with every single
request that you send.
So one request can bias
towards a digit sequence,
and the next request can
bias towards somebody's name,
for example.
All of this can be accomplished
with the speech adaptation API
that I was talking about before.
The speech adaptation API today
has three different components
or options.
First is phrase hints.
This is the ability to send
words or long phrases which
you think may be present in
the speech or in the text,
and the system will
do its best to look
at the words and
combinations of words
biased towards that particular
piece of information.
In some cases, though,
that might not be enough
or might not be giving you
granular enough control,
and that's what the
boost API is for.
The boost API allows you to
specify an actual weight value
for a specific
word or bigram that
will then take effect on that
word or bigram in the word
lattice.
This is especially
useful for things
like proper nouns or rare words
because you can significantly
boost the likelihood of
them being recommended.
Finally, we have
the classes feature,
which is essentially pre-built
phrase hints and boost
values for common scenarios.
For example, an alphanumeric
sequence or a digit
sequence, being able to
recognize that without having
to set the values yourself.
Coming soon, we will
have some additions
to the speech
adaptation API, namely
custom classes which will
allow users to create and share
their own premade
classes that can then
be used with boost or speech
adaptation the same way
classes can today.
This doesn't make the system
necessarily any more accurate,
but it gives users much
greater composability
when they are working on
these problems in the way
that they can specify
phrases or words that they
want to bias towards.
Next is saved
context, which allows
you to save one or many known
good biasing configurations
and specify that entire phrase
list or boost list with just
an ID on subsequent calls.
This can be very useful in
saving bandwidth overhead
for users that need to send
thousands or tens of thousands
of words in each context.
So that gives you an
overview of the biasing tools
and the model
customization tools
that we have available
within the Google speech API.
We're always trying
to improve these,
but ultimately, these
tools are just how you send
and how you give the
biasing information.
The real hard part
is figuring out
what the right biasing
information to send to the API
is, and that's what we're
going to talk about next.
So broadly, some
things to consider
are, what am I doing
with this transcript?
So when you are
transcribing the audio,
is the result going
into some NLU system
where you need to
extract an entity?
Is it being displayed
directly to a user?
Are there specific things
that the downstream systems
are going to be sensitive to?
If your goal is to
capture a phone number,
then you have to be
absolutely positive
that you're getting
that digit sequence
right every single time.
Next thing to
consider is, are there
rare words or proper nouns?
Rare words and proper nouns are
very difficult for ASR systems
because, statistically
speaking, they occur very, very
uncommonly in everyday
speech, so it's less likely
that a speech-to-text system
is going to recommend that that
is the word in the series
of phonemes as opposed
to a homonym of a
more common word.
This can be
complicated, but this
is why biasing towards these
words very, very highly
can cause them to be recommended
at the rate which you want.
The next is, what contextual
information can I use?
So this is, what external
information outside
of the audio itself
can I use to figure out
what the person might
be talking about?
So examples of this would be
context or state in a chat bot
application.
Maybe you have a user history.
So you know the types of queries
that the user usually makes,
and you can use that
to help increase
accuracy on future queries.
And that feeds into the
final point, which is, do I
have strong or weak context?
So when you think about
that contextual information
that you have, you
should be thinking about,
do I know exactly what
the user is going to say
and I'm pretty sure I know how
they're going to verbalize it?
Or do I just know
broad categories
of what this is about?
Some examples of strong
context would be a IVR,
like a phone-answering bot
scenario where exactly that
the user is about to give a
phone number, or say yes or no,
or something like that.
Next would be a system for
giving commands or [INAUDIBLE]
system where that
the user is going
to say, change the channel,
or play songs by some artist.
In these systems, you have very,
very constrained vocabulary,
and this can help you to
bias and increase accuracy
on that specific vocabulary.
And finally, as I talked
about before, important words
or entities--
if you have a proper noun that's
very important to transcribe
correctly, you're
almost always going
to need to bias towards
it very, very strongly.
Next, we have weak
context, which
is a situation like captions,
or dictation, or perhaps
a conversation
between two people
or multiple people in a meeting.
And these are
situations where you
don't know exactly
what somebody is going
to say at any one moment,
but you know broadly what
they are talking about.
For example, this
recording is all
about speech-to-text
technology, and that
might give you hints about
what words are going to be said
or are common that you can
use to increase accuracy
on those words.
So now that we've looked
at the biasing tools
that are available
as well as what
to think about when you're
starting to think about biasing
and model
customization, I'm going
to take you through a demo or
really more of a worked example
on what it looks like
to do biasing for real.
Now, this is going to be
a very simple example.
We've also created
a bunch of content
to go along with this
next on-air session
where you'll actually be able
to try all of this for yourself
in a quick lap.
For the purpose
of this demo, I'm
going to be focusing
on improvement type two
that I talked about where
we're going to tweak weights
to address specific words and
phrases issues, especially
focused on rare words and
proper nouns, as you'll see.
So to get started
here, I'm going
to do basically exactly what
I told you not to do before,
which is I'm going to give
this example based on just one
phrase and one sentence.
I don't have a whole
corpus of audio here,
but the goal is not necessarily
to vastly improve this one
phrase, but to
just show you how I
think about the biasing
problem and the signals
that you can use and
apply to a larger corpus
when you're doing this
yourself or trying it out
in the quick lap.
So I've recorded a single
sentence of me speaking here
that I'll play for you.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hi, this is Calum.
I'm talking about
the speakotron.
[END PLAYBACK]
So you can see I say my
name, a proper noun, as well
as a totally made-up
word, speakotron.
Now, even with these
rare words, like I said,
the Google recognizer works
very well out of the box,
so I actually didn't have any
issues recognizing this audio
originally.
So I had to make the
problem a little bit harder
for our speech
recognition system,
and to do that, I
added some noise
to this same audio recording.
And this is the
audio recording I'll
be using for all the future
examples in the demo,
so I'll play that for you now.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
Hi, this is Calum.
I'm talking about
the speakotron.
[END PLAYBACK]
So as you can see, exact same
sentence with some white noise
added in the
background that made it
so that the ASR system
wasn't recognizing it
right out of the box.
On the right-hand side,
I've set up some Python code
to try out sending this to
the Cloud speech recognizer.
I've specified my input file.
I'm using US English since I'm
a American English speaker.
This file is a
basic linear PCM WAV
file recorded at 16 kilohertz.
I'm not sending
any speech context
yet because I just
want to see what
the bare usage of the system is.
Next, I need to setup
my simple WER script,
so I'm putting in my ground
truth hypothesis here,
hi, this is Calum.
I'm talking about
the speakotron.
I haven't included any
punctuation in this case,
but you could
include punctuation
if you're expecting punctuation
in the result as well.
The hypothesis will come
directly from the Google speech
transcript that I just
set up, and then we
will compute the error rate
and pre-print the HTML.
So let's take a look at what the
accuracy looks like right out
of the box on this noisy file.
I had a word error
rate of 37.5%, driven
all by substitution error here.
So we can see it
got my name wrong.
Not that wrong, but it
is spelled incorrectly.
But more concerning,
instead of "the speakotron",
it was transcribed as "this
Eco tron", which is not good.
If we were really worried about
the speakotron product here,
then we would have
not even captured
that this phrase was about
the speakotron product.
So let's look at what we can do.
Using the phrase hint API, I
could do something very simple
like put the exact right
transcription in as a phrase,
hi, this is Calum.
I'm talking about
the speakotron.
Now, this did work.
This did result in
0% Word Error Rate
and the phrase being
transcribed perfectly.
This is always a
good thing to try out
if you have a single phrase.
It basically just shows you
that speech adaptation as tools
work.
We are actually operating on
the lattice and changing things,
but this isn't
that helpful to you
as you think about
improving recognition
across an entire corpus
because if you knew what
the correct transcription
of the phrase was,
you wouldn't be sending it to
the speech API to begin with.
So I don't think
this is that helpful,
and sending the whole
phrase is also not
going to be helpful to other
words where somebody is saying,
hey, this is some
other name, or they
are verbalizing the phrase
a little bit differently.
So let's think about what we
can do to increase recognition
without just going for the
full phrase being accurate.
We could use the boost API
and look at the rare words,
like I talked
about doing before.
Calum and speakotron here
are the two rare words,
and by boosting them
fairly significantly,
I think we can get pretty
good results on those words.
So let's take a look at how that
performed on our noisy version
of the audio.
I was able to decrease the Word
Error Rate substantially just
by doing this, where I've got
to spell my name correctly,
and instead of Eco
tron, it has correctly
recognized speakotron.
But there is still an
error of it actually
thinks it's saying
"this" speakotron and not
"the" speakotron.
Now, this is an easy fix
on the phrase side, too,
but it got me
thinking more broadly
about what you can
do to increase this,
not just for this one
phrase, but all phrases
that are talking
about the speakotron
or that are talking about some--
somebody saying their name
is Calum.
And one thing we
can do with boost
is to boost not just
the unigrams that
are important to us,
but also the bigrams.
We wouldn't want to boost really
anything more than a bigram
because you're just going
to significantly confuse
the lattice since those phrases
are never going to exist
like that in the lattice.
But by thinking about what
are the bigrams where people
are going to actually
use these rare words,
we can greatly
increase recognition.
So when somebody's
saying their name,
they're usually going to say
"is" name, my name is Calum,
or this is Calum.
And you could also think
of other verbalizations.
And when I thought about
speakotron, I thought,
people are probably going to
say "the" speakotron or "a"
speakotron, the article
with it basically,
and we can use that to
boost those bi grams as well
as the unigrams
even more strongly.
And that's going to help us get
even better recognition in some
of those scenarios.
And so in this case, I boosted
the bigram and the unigram.
I've chosen boost
values of five and 10.
I think you'll have to play with
exactly what boost value works
best for you, but
generally speaking,
the bigram with
the article should
be boosted at a lower
rate than the unit gram
because you wouldn't want
every single word after "the"
to be transcribed
as "the" speakotron.
And with that, I was
able to actually get down
to 0% Word Error Rate, and we
have an accurate transcript.
Like I said, this is just
working on one single phrase,
and you would never
get to 0% Word Error
Rate on an entire corpus or
multiple different variations
on this same phrase,
but hopefully this
gives you a helpful
idea about the way
to think about these
problems and what
you can do to, overall,
decrease Word Error Rate
across the corpus.
So if you are interested in
trying this out for yourself
or finding out more
information about improving
speech accuracy for your data,
you can check out our docs.
We've recently updated the
speech adaptation documentation
to include a number
of the best practices
that I've just
talked about here.
If you want to actually
try it out for real,
we've created a quick lab
specifically to go along
with this content called
"Measuring and Improving
Speech Accuracy" where you can
try out using the simple word
script and tuning the
biasing with boost,
and phrase hints,
and classes and try
to achieve the greatest
word error rate reduction
for yourself.
If you're interested
in the features
that I talked about
before the custom
classes or the saved context,
you can apply for alpha access.
Calumbarnes@google.com is
how to get in touch with me.
Thanks very much,
and I wish you best
of luck with all of
your speech accuracy.